we need a numerical procedure which is
easy in one direction and hard in the
other this brings us to modular
arithmetic also known as clock
arithmetic for example to find 46 mod 12
we could take a rope of length 46 units
and wrap it around a clock of 12 units
which is called the modulus and where
the rope ends is the solution so we say
46 mod 12 is congruent to 10 easy now
to make this work we use a prime modulus
such as 17 then we find a primitive root
of 17 in this case 3 which has this
important property that when raised to
different exponents the solution
distributes uniformly around the clock 3
is known as the generator if we raise 3
to any exponent X then the solution is
equally likely to be any integer between
0 and 17 now the reverse procedure is
hard say given 12 find the exponent 3
needs to be raised 2 this is called the
discrete logarithm problem and now we
have our one wave function easy to
perform but hard to reverse given 12 we
would have to resort to trial and error
to find matching exponents how hard is
this well with small numbers it's easy
but if we use a prime modulus which is
hundreds of digits long it becomes
impractical to solve even if you had
access to all computational power on
earth it could take thousands of years
to run through all possibilities so the
strength of a one-way function is based
on the time needed to reverse it